hello and welcome to GameSpot of Thrones
you are watching just a small segment of
a much larger program where we discuss
in-depth Game of Thrones Season six
Episode one the red woman if you'd like
to see the full episode be sure to head
to youtube.com slash GameSpot beware of
spoilers so if if a tree falls in the
forest does it make a sound
mmm if a game of Thrones character dies
of screen are they really dead mmm I'm
gonna talk about an old favorite
character mine
Kasia where Akasha mine back to series
one cereal ferrell build Braavosi water
dancer now I know people are already
type in the comments saying wait the
writers confirmed to Maisie Williams
that serios dead mm well what if he
wasn't always Syria
oh no so I think potentially he could be
the wife I think it's more plausible
that he is somehow connected and still
alive in the ER with the many-faced God
okay is he's still hanging around so
explain yourself sir I intend to so we
do see him have a fight in series one
after the Lannisters come to take Arya
Stark and he dispatches for Lannister
guards or Lannister guards thought a
wooden sword at that and then he faces
off with a Meryn lovely Submariner in
trance who breaks his sword and you hear
her who here you know combat as areas
running away but a few seasons later
area confides in the Hound and says
Marin killed my friend and he says the
greatest swordsman who ever lived killed
by Meryn [ __ ] Trant is that number
any boy [ __ ] with a sword could beat
three Meryn Trant
Syrio didn't have a sword or armor just
a stick where the thoughts were never
lived in a before thinking wrong pretty
sure the first sword of Braavos is
better than you know any boy [ __ ] with
a sword so I really don't think he's
dead but where is he now where is now
well I feel like to Braavos okay so
there are some definitely some parallels
between the Braavosi water dancer
and the men without faces so he if he's
not one then he's definitely a part of
them hmm so the connection span of all
six series I mean obviously there's the
what do we say to the god of death
that's fairly obvious one but then he
has a line the full line is the heart
lies and the head plays tricks with us
for the icy true look at your eyes now
Aereo is currently blind hmm and his
sight taken away from her in the books
that Serio actually blindfolds area as
part of her training
so maybe permanent blindness is an
extension of a training maybe the
blindfold was him preparing her for this
training I have chance that she would
you know venture further down this path
are you with your logic well you know
I've got to have you know some good
moments and in the first lesson with
Syrio area turns up late just after
midday and he says tomorrow you'll be
here at midday throws worse or she
misses it picks up tomorrow you'll catch
it and then the wave after battering her
with a stick or a wooden sword they're
not the same she says I will see you
tomorrow
I maybe I'm just seeing what I want to
see maybe I'm holding onto that thing of
if they died off-screen are they really
dead maybe you're a fan of the musical
annie'
maybe I've done a reference to show
tomorrow that's well like I got it do
you guys do you guys think that this
theory of the survival of the
charismatic water dancer holds water oh
god that was worse than mine um honestly
deep down I want it to be true and I
think you've made some good points there
some less good points also but I'm gonna
play devil's advocate here right first
of all how would Syria or whatever his
real name is know that she was going to
end up in Braavos and be blind that's
pretty that's a pretty wild guess that
he would have to make it could just be
as his training that he had to the man
without faces that they knew blindness
was a way to kind of a chin your other
skills maybe they talked with each other
and so like maybe he knew jaqen H'ghar
maybe he is jaqen H'ghar
we just don't know my second point is
Dave tomorrow is quite a common word I
know that
to point out the tap the the parallels
yeah okay daily training with one person
daily training with another person
wooden sticks hmm both having their site
taken away I mean it doesn't happen in
the first series of the show but it
happens in the books mm-hmm it's
happening Kate it's to brace it we'll
see so excited
Syrio is both in the show and he's still
here Oh Oh God you know hearts forever
you